Everyone knows that Mary-Kate and Ashley Olsen
used their super twin powers to bring Michelle
Tanner to life on Full House.
"No way Jose."
But a twin stepping in as a body double or
playing half of the role isn't just reserved
for fussy toddlers.
Identical twins have popped up in lots of
films and TV shows without you ever noticing.
And while some on-screen doubles aren't quite
perfect fits…
"My name is Julius, and I'm ya twin brother."
"Oh, obviously!"
...you might be surprised at some of the roles
that were played by twins.
Sophia Burset in Orange is the New Black
One of the slickest twin twists in TV history
is in the Netflix smash, based on Piper Kerman's
prison memoir.
Creator Jenji Kohan and her crew tried to
use transgender icon Laverne Cox in her character's
pre-transition flashback scenes.
But the episode's famous director wasn't buying
Sophia as "Marcus" ...
"And Jodie Foster directed this episode, so
I was like, 'I'm gonna have to butch it up,'
because Jodie I don't think believed that
I could, I could pull this off.
And I go to Jodie, and she looks at me and
she's like, 'we're going to have to hire someone.'"
Fortunately, they didn't have to look far.
They decided to hire Cox's identical twin,
a composer and singer who performs under the
name "M. Lamar," who proved to be a perfect
fit.
He had no previous acting experience or training,
but you wouldn't know it — his performance
and look was so seamless, most viewers probably
just assumed it was Cox in the role of Marcus,
aided by Hollywood magic …
"My friends were like, 'How did they do that,
was that like CGI or something?'"
Sarah Connor in Terminator 2: Judgment Day
Science fiction fans and critics raved over
Linda Hamilton's badass performance in T2
"You broke my arm!"
"There are 215 bones in the human body.
That's one."
… and in a few scenes, audiences were graced
with double the Hamilton, most notably when
the T-1000 mimics Sarah Connor.
Director James Cameron didn't need to break
out the early-'90s CGI magic or pull an old-school
Patty Duke split-screen...
"One pair of matching bookends / Different
as night and day"
Cameron simply used Hamilton's identical twin
sister Leslie to get the shot.
Xander Harris in Buffy the Vampire Slayer
In the season five episode "The Replacement,"
Xander lovers were treated to a double dose
of sarcasm and snark.
"What if we do if this doesn't work?"
"Kill us both, Spock!"
To pull off the trick on a skimpy TV budget,
the show used a very lo-fi solution: Nicholas
Brendon's identical twin brother Kelly Donovan.
Brendon, however, still performed both roles
— Donovan only spoke when both Xanders had
lines in the same scene.
"Cover your eyes!"
"This?"
"It will melt your brain!"
Claire Kincaid in Law & Order
Actress Jill Hennessy was once so busy in
her role as assistant district attorney on
the long-running NBC procedural she literally
needed to be in two places at once.
Fortunately, she has a twin who happily filled
Claire Kincaid's shoes.
In 1996, Jacqueline Hennessy worked as an
uncredited stand-in for her sister in a few
scenes in one season six episode because Jill
was busy filming a crossover episode of Homicide:
Life on the Street.
This wasn't Jacqueline's first time on camera.
The Hennessy sisters made their film debut
as twin escorts in the 1988 David Cronenberg
film Dead Ringers.
Court Foster in The Man in the Moon
Actor Jason London, best known for his role
in 1993's Dazed and Confused, made his film
debut in the 1991 coming-of-age drama The
Man in the Moon.
His twin Jeremy — best known for Party of
Five and Mallrats — was actually the one
who wanted to audition for the film and convinced
his brother to drive him there.
Jason read for the part, too, beating his
brother out … but Jeremy was still involved
with the production.
While Jason got to do all of the acting — including
kissing Reese Witherspoon in her film debut
— his twin brother Jeremy was on hand for
all the unglamorous stunt work … including
the infamous tractor incident.
So...that sucks for him.
The Matrix
Though the 1999 science-fiction classic used
cutting edge special effects for some revolutionary
shots, the Wachowskis chose to go practical
for the agent training scene.
As Neo walks through the stream of people,
if you look closely, you can see that faces
keep repeating.
That's because the crowd is full of identical
siblings.
The directing duo said they couldn't afford
to pull off the effect digitally at the time,
so they ended up hiring as many twins or triplets
as they could find in Sydney, where the film
was shot.
So if you've ever wondered why that scene
felt extra creepy, there's your answer.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!